how many people do you think are
migrants if you watch the news you might
think it's a large share refugee crisis
new EU migrants distil in your pocket
and so immigrant Oh in fact migrants
make up only around 3.5 percent of the
world's population of these 10 percent
of refugees the vast majority are
economic migrants if more people
migrated the world would be a lot richer
the best estimate says that if people
were allowed to work where they wanted
the world's GDP would be roughly double
but many people in rich countries don't
want to let more people in and the
debate fears between fear mongering and
moralizing we have a president who is a
racist xenophobe religious bigot so what
should governments do to get migration
right these people are migrants living
in Australia
almost a third of people in Australia
were born somewhere else it has the
highest migrant share of population of
all the big oacd countries and almost
double that of America migration was
hugely benefited Australia Australian
population has doubled since the 1970s
and the economy has grown 22 fold and
it's also become a more exciting and
interesting country Australia has not
had a recession for 28 years thanks
partly to its openness to foreign talent
you can go to neighborhoods of Sydney
where we hear a variety of different
languages spoken and you get ideas from
everywhere and it makes it easier for
them to have trading connections with
the rest of the world Anna has been a
Sydneysider for almost two years I know
the definition is that I moved here as a
migrant but I wouldn't call myself a
migrant being non-white I think people
like me get the impression that that was
used in a very negative way I want to
call myself a global person because I
believe I can live and work anywhere in
the world she moved here with her family
from India we were looking at an option
out of India we lived in India all our
lives I'd been here on holiday in 2008
when I loved the country and that was at
that point that I started thinking about
it I was very excited until the 1970s
Australia had immigration rules that
strongly favored Europeans people called
it the White Australia Policy but since
then the system has been colorblind
and the number of migrants coming from
China and India has rapidly increased in
the 12 months leading up to June 2018
Australia gave out just over 160,000
permanent work visas ana received one of
them
Australia gives out far more visas
relative to its population than Britain
or America it shows that a country can
be very open to immigration and very
successful but it has to be done the
right way wouldn't want to have such a
big influx so suddenly that you ended up
undermining the institutions that make
rich countries rich in the first place
but what we do know is that you can
manage a much higher level of migration
than is normal at the moment and how do
we know that because it's happened you
look at somewhere like Australia any
rich country could manage that level of
migration and then if that works
open the gates a bit more you could
design a policy that was better both for
the native-born and for the rest of the
world Australia has found a formula that
works Anna came on a skilled independent
visa which allows her and her family to
live in Australia permanently and
without needing a job in advance the
advantages they value your previous work
experience in Australia which is a good
thing because they're not just looking
for entry-level professions Anna's
application was accepted because she
scored highly on Australia's
points-based system here's how it works
people who want to move to Australia can
put forward an expression of interest
they are then awarded points based on
their qualifications their age how well
they speak English and what skills and
work experience they have those with the
highest number of points are invited to
apply to the Australian government
[Music]
Madeleine sumption is a migration policy
expert a points-based system is used in
Australia Canada New Zealand and a
handful of other countries generally in
order to increase immigration the
points-based system puts the government
in the driving seat and they decide what
characteristics they think are important
the Australian government decides which
industries it thinks most need migrants
it doesn't always get it right
some migrants get visas but can't find a
job
I think getting your first job in
Australia is a big challenge and I think
it depends on where you come from as an
experienced project manager Anna got a
job quickly most migrants in Australia
find work within 18 months but critics
say the government should give more say
to employers when deciding whom to let
into the country in most other rich
countries the rules are very different
if you come from a poor country it's
extremely hard to migrate legally to a
rich one unless you already have a
well-paid job offer or are a close
relative of a citizen the rules in
America are particularly baffling
America's current system is more
restrictive than Australia and less
selective a large majority of the people
who get permanent residents there do so
via family reunification so because they
have a relative there I'm only a smaller
portion get in because they have skills
they have a system that was designed
quite a long time ago and politically it
has been very difficult for them to
change anything and so they have a
number of quite rigid caps which means
that they've generated big backlogs the
demand for visas is so high they're
simply allocating visas by lottery
another issue in the United States is
that it borders Latin America so a lot
of immigrants can enter illegally simply
by dodging the border guards clearly not
a problem shared by Australia it's an
island so you can't just walk in anyone
who comes without permission will be
spotted by the Coast Guard they control
their borders very closely the fact that
they're ruthlessly selective that makes
it easier for them to be generous
because Australians really do feel that
they are in control of who comes
Australia's migration success story has
made public opinion generally positive
towards immigrants everyone at school is
very welcoming my workplace was amazing
the everyday Australian has been really
nice and warm so it's been a great
experience but even here there's still a
sizable number of people who want to
slow the pace of migration I think the
attitude of migration is not as
Australian it's everywhere in the world
now it's usually apprehension from a
very personal point of view that people
think there's possibly a loss of their
own lifestyle in a democracy no
migration policy can succeed unless it
wins and retains the consent of voters
[Music]
some natives strongly object to
newcomers they argue that immigrants
dragged down wages for the locals and
take more out of the welfare state than
they put in both charges are usually
false but governments could adopt
policies that make it absolutely clear
that migrants pay their way if you said
to migrants coming to rich countries yes
you can come but you're gonna have to
pay a little bit of extra tax to do that
they would be extremely willing and then
suddenly that might change the picture
of how people see it people will see it
as more of an opportunity and less of a
hassle
a migrant tax could be spent on things
that voters like such as pensions or
public health or the government could
simply send the money to voters they
could also restrict migrants access to
the welfare state this could be for a
set number of years as in Britain or
permanently like in the Gulf countries
that would answer the economic
complaints about migration but what are
the cultural ones some voters fear the
disruption that rapid migration can
cause refugees do not assimilate this
destroyed migrants tend to cluster which
means that some neighborhoods really do
change uncomfortably fast governments
can encourage immigrants to learn the
local language and understand the
culture but many natives prefer their
societies the way they are
overcoming all these objections will be
hard but Australia shows that a country
can be twice as open to immigration as
America and the result is not a disaster
as nativist predict but decades of peace
and rising prosperity governments need
to show voters two things that they get
to choose who comes and that migrants
put more in than they take out when they
see this voters might be happy to open
the door wider if you want to learn more
about migration you can click the link
opposite to find further economists
coverage some research data and studies
used to make this film if you want to
watch more films like this don't forget
to subscribe thanks for watching
you